♪ ♪
>> Laura: THE DEMOCRATS AND
THEIR MEDIA LACKEYS ARE TRYING
TO CONVINCE VOTERS, ESPECIALLY
SENIORS AND SUBURBAN WOMEN,
ELECTING JOE BIDEN WILL RETURN
EVERYTHING TO A CALM STATE.
BUT OF COURSE, THE OPPOSITE IS
TRUE.
THE PAST MONTH DEMONSTRATES
BEYOND A SHADOW OF A DOUBT THAT
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE BECOME THE
PARTY OF CHAOS, LAWLESSNESS, AND
DISORDER.
NOW, THEY NOT ONLY WANT TO
DEFEAT PRESIDENT TRUMP, THAT IS
OBVIOUS, THEY WANT TO CHANGE THE
COUNTRY IN WAYS THAT WOULD BE
EXTREMELY DANGEROUS.
THEY WILL DEFUND THE POLICE AND
THE MILITARY, AND WHEN THEY
CAN’T GET THEIR WAY THROUGH
VOTING, THEY WILL ENCOURAGE
RIOTING AND LOOTING.
IF YOU RESIST OR PUBLICLY
PROFESS YOUR WHITE GUILT, THEY
WILL DESTROY YOU.
THEY HATE OUR HISTORY, OUR
TRADITIONS, AND OUR WAY OF LIFE.
THEY HATE OUR CONSTITUTION,
WHICH THEY SEE HAS THIS THING
WRITTEN BY A BUNCH OF CORRUPT
WHITE SLAVEHOLDERS.
THEY WANT TO TAKE MOST OF YOUR
MONEY AND EVENTUALLY ALL OF YOUR
PRIVATE PROPERTY.
THEY WANT NEVER ENDING LOCKDOWNS
AND MANDATES FOR EVERYTHING FROM
MASTS TO WHEN YOU CAN GO TO
CHURCH.
YET NANCY PELOSI WON’T EVEN MAKE
THE HOUSE SHOW UP IN PERSON TO
VOTE ON ANY OF THIS.
NO LEGISLATION, JUST ANNOUNCE
IT.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY HAVE BECOME
NONESSENTIAL IN CONGRESS.
THEY ARE NOT EVEN PRETENDING TO
BE THE PEOPLE DON’T LIKE THE
PEOPLE’S REPRESENTATIVES
ANYMORE.
MORE CHAOS IS COMING.
WE HAVE ONE CHANCE TO STOP IT.
IF YOU LOVE YOUR COUNTRY, IF YOU
LOVE WESTERN SALE CIVILIZATION
AND WANT TO SIT WITH RULE OF
LAW, YOU MUST STAND OUT.
YOU MUST BE WILLING TO SUIT UP
FOR THIS BATTLE.
IN SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS, TOWN
COUNCIL MEETINGS, MAYBE EVEN A
PARENT/TEACHER CONFERENCES AND
OF COURSE STATE AND FEDERAL
ELECTIONS.
IT IS TIME TO DO-OR-DIE.
TO FIND OUT HOW RADICALIZED THE
LEFT HAS GOTTEN AND JUST THE
LAST FEW WEEKS, PROFESSOR ERIC
COACHMAN AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
LONDON ASKED AMERICANS A SERIES
OF QUESTIONS THAT EVEN HE
THOUGHT WERE TOO CRAZY FOR
ANYONE TO ACTUALLY TO SUPPORT.
BUT WHAT HE ACTUALLY FOUND WAS
SHOCKING.
FOR STARTERS, 70% OF SELF
IDENTIFIED LIBERALS SUPPORTING
WELL NOW REWRITING THE
CONSTITUTION TO A NEW AMERICAN
CONSTITUTION THAT BETTER
REFLECTS OUR DIVERSITY AS A
PEOPLE.
FURTHERMORE, 60% OF VERY LIBERAL
RESPONDENTS FAVOR REMOVING
STATUES OF WHITE MEN FROM PUBLIC
PLACES UNTIL THE STOCK OF
STATUES MATCHES THE DEMOGRAPHICS
OF THE ENTIRE POPULATION.